you're going to live under laws because
of the kind of thing you are
and if you live under bad laws you're
going to be miserable
what's a country a country has borders
that's the latest news isn't it yeah and
uh
okay so that's the edge of a country
what's inside there it's a group of
citizens
that have engaged in a contract together
to be ruled by the same government so it
takes contract
according to modern political thought
but there's an interesting sentence in
the declaration of independence
that we will read see if we can find it
so it says whenever any form of
government becomes destructive of these
ends
it is the right of the people to alter
or to abolish it
and to institute new government lay its
foundation on such principles
so we can change the government it's a
right
but then what follows from that
i kind of have a duty to establish a new
set of rules in law
so the directorate's independence
doesn't contemplate
life without government does it
how does it begin it begins in very
general terms in that
it can be applied it's not specific to
america it can be applied
human events means really anytime one
people can be any people
universally right isn't that interesting
uh they began universally but how does
it end
let's look at the last sentence
and for the support somebody read this
and for the support of this declaration
with a firm reliance on the protection
of divine providence we mutually pledge
to each other
our lives our fortunes and our sacred
honor
what else do they have to pledge except
those things
that's a pledge of everything right
we pledge all of that and who do they
pledge it to
each other they're promising each other
see that's a big pledge and a pledge of
everything
and in the name of who do they make this
pledge
divine providence yeah who's that
their creator yeah as was mentioned in
the beginning of the declaration of
independence so god
right they swear to god
and to each other
we have fraternities at hillsdale
college and i won't say that they're
not sometimes a little naughty and
and they all take pledges
oh to join the fraternity and the o's
are all the same they're all 19th
century christian organizations these
fraternities
and we're big oath takers around here as
you know we're just like these guys
right in the deck where i spent minutes
so
so all you got to do is remind them of
their oath you know
what you do they you know kind of will
you know and you say well
i forget now what you promise to do
in your oath to your fraternity and it's
always the all of the oaths are to god
and each other
many of them to the college too that
means i really got them right
they got to straighten up now and and
that's a
it's a big deal with war pending right
and this is particular right
the the people in the room you know
about four times as many as is around
this table
swear to each other i swear to
emily and emily swears to me and that
means later
we don't do it we know the name and
can picture the face of the person who's
going to disapprove
who's been betrayed right and that's
as particular as it can possibly get
but it begins
was it casey who said that universally
no it wasn't that's garrison good job
yeah it begins
universally it begins without reference
to any place or any people but to
every place and every people and it ends
with the
utmost particularity you know if you
think
every choice you make
you've always got some sense of right
when you make a choice
this document moves from this ultimate
sense of right that we all carry
down to the particular circumstances in
which they are going to act
right now and the whole document
is a connected chain from the general
to the particular and it's exactly the
process
every one of us goes through every time
we make a hard choice
that interesting thank you for watching
we hope you're enjoying our highlight
series and invite you to explore
all of hillsdale college's online
courses they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn